so it's been a little while since I've
done a vlog and loads of people have
been asking for one so I thought why not
give you a little taste this is gonna be
a week in my new life as a full-time
youtuber video maker science
communicator still not quite sure what's
call myself well
[Music]
so a few updates for those of you who
might miss them one I handed him a
thesis and did my vote and I've got my
corrections to do hey as a matter of
fact that is literally what I was doing
this morning I was working through my
corrections on my theory chapter two I
made the decision to become a full-time
science communicator whatever I want to
call myself and it's been going very
well basically like past couple of
months when I've been kind of easing
into doing this full-time have been a
really really fun actually I'm really
enjoying it as hopefully you'll see in
this video that's probably too close and
three I have moved back home for the
time being basically this is my kind of
office studio where this is where I've
been making everything and this is a
spare room in my parents house where I
am back for a couple of months because
Pixlr and I are looking for a place to
live together but she is finishing off
her PGCE
which means that she's living on her own
and basically it's a couple of months I
don't mind living at home for a couple
of months it's rent free it's nice you
know the other housemates are all right
I love my parents dearly but I am
looking forward to moving out I've got
the means to support living somewhere
else like I'm making enough money to to
not live at home I'm just willing to
wait until picks ago and I get somewhere
together so you know short time so what
am I doing with my time at the moment
well every week's been completely
different really this week you can be
seeing a lot of video making there's two
videos I want to get out this week as
well as making this vlog there's also
gonna be me giving a talk at Bristol uni
which is gonna be I need to write that
but also gonna be getting some treatment
for this bad boy because I screwed up my
legs kind of really hurt we've got the
podcast recording we've got loads of
editing and Ashley I need to be editing
right now I'm behind on a video so all
day and for the past several days I've
been working on this script on a history
of pi pi day is this Wednesday if
currently Monday I really need to film
this tonight when I shoot a video this
is my view well I mean like normally
there be a camera but you get the idea
okay it's currently just before 1 a.m.
which means now it's actually Tuesday
I'm about to shoot my PI video I
wouldn't normally be shooting this late
but I've been working on the script
keep kept revising it basically I think
I'm happy with it now we're as happy as
I can be I actually have just reached a
point right now to shoot so green screen
behind me
I'm sure this footage won't get co-opted
for any reason I know it's time to film
a video about a mathematical constant
two hours well hopefully less because I
now have this tablet in front of me
which means hopefully it will take less
time we'll see two hours later oh my
goodness is 3:00 a.m.
finally done like it's easier with the
tablet for sure but it's a long video so
it takes a while incidentally if you're
interested in how I make these videos
every time I do a shoot I try and do it
behind the scenes on my patreon lens so
like Instagram stories but just for
people who support me on patreon so
there's a link to the patreon down there
in the description if you'd like to
support me then yeah I try and do behind
the scenes stuff every day on that oh my
god I've got a day to edit this all
right now it's actually Tuesday and it's
before 9:00 I've been editing and
getting the assembly ready of this
history of Pi video it's interesting to
see just how tired I look in this
footage I was Wow well I mean it was
early okay so already has been synced
and cleaned up and the noise from it
I've also done the chroma key so I've
removed myself from the green screen
background and now I'm just gonna be
chopping together the video based on the
script so this point very crude just
getting the lines in the right place and
identifying the best text for each line
this is gonna take a little while okay
so the assembly cut is now finished I've
put all the clips where I want them to
be in the timeline now it's a question
of fine-tuning it getting the frames and
transitions exactly right and doing all
the graphics and the sound it's
currently lunch productive morning
ashlee life at the moment is basically
kind of 90% video editing it feels like
like I'm not at a point as a YouTube
I can afford to pay somebody else to do
work for me no that is not a request for
offers it's very kind but I still enjoy
doing everything myself for now but it
means that a lot of what I do is
actually quite similar to a PhD in that
I'm just sat on a desk and doing
something quite mentally taxing really
for way too many hours in the day like
I'm probably going to I'm kind of
stopping working about 10:00 in the
evening every day at the moment which is
you know quite long hours before I'd
kept all of the equipment up just in
case I needed to film anything extra
this morning unfortunately I didn't
that's all now they're waiting to be
used again that live a jungle also there
are still books strewn everywhere from
when I did a video about my favorite
physics books and oh and I got this
thing so one of the things which
happened in the New York trip which I
didn't actually show you because the
footage was all completely silent as I
talked about in a previous vlog I got
this l'm Ettrick la metric thing hang on
let me focus on it there you go so it's
a smart clock you can get it to display
hang on and the focus of attention thank
you you can get it to display things
like your Twitter followers or the time
or you know it's a clock or your YouTube
subscribers or in my case that's the
views on the video I've released most
recently which is to me more valuable
information than my subscribers so
that's kind of nice to have in the
background also next to my stolen
stormtrooper lamp quite a lot has
happened recently now I think of it on
the floor something that happened a long
time ago though was I did some filming
with the BBC for a series of videos on
ABC bite size which is the BBC's
revision service and they finally come
out like well over here later so I have
a vlog stored which I need to quickly
edit about that experience they only
came out yesterday so that's to come out
and that's where that came from
i I was offered it after I kind of took
it so it doesn't really come out
stealing apparently this vlog is just me
getting successively lower to the
grounds the other thing that happened
recently was I was on the news for those
of you that don't live in Western Europe
it got really really cold here recently
and that's because of my research a
certain status
very warming happened which for those of
you who've watched my PhD vlogs will
know that was what I researched for four
years and so I'm kind of a world expert
on the tropospheric impacts of sudden
warming's
which is really weird to say and as such
I got called up by Sky News I did a live
TV interview with them and I also
appeared in a special I was interviewed
by CNN that was a little bit crazy like
I went into this vlog expecting that
nothing happens in my life but I think
back has happened what needs to happen
now though is for me to finish this
video today because it's pi day tomorrow
I have to get this finished today we're
in a good position though after lunch I
finished up the assembly and did the
fine-tuning and trimming and everything
and also did the color correction so
tweaking what the camera took in and
what you guys see in the end adjusting
color temperature the exposure things
like that
now it's the really nitpicky going
through and adding graphics and doing
animations and adding text and then
adding music so it looks like 80% done
but it's probably only about 50% of the
work so far so I think tonight is also
going to be a very late night
[Music]
good morning my alarm just went off on
my phone and I know that it went off
despite the fact that it's in the office
because I haven't left the office I
worked all night I actually pulled my
first ever editing all-nighter
whenever I've done it before it's been
verb like work I'm very tired but this
video is so nearly done I'm at the point
where I literally just need to do the
final mix at the music in make sure
everything's tweaked exactly right and
then export it and then hope that there
aren't any errors and the computer
actually you know works then upload and
plug it on social media and collapse
it's a good plan one hour later I just
got to the end of doing the sound mixing
and my computer's completely crashed if
I don't get this video out today this
morning there would be no point
whatsoever in staying up all night are
you kidding me now one utility later oh
my god so video is finished that has
been 36 hours of unbelievably stressful
like intense effort that's that's like
the first thing I've done post thesis
which has been insanely stressful 36
hours from shooting to getting a
complete educational video done that's
like 17 minutes long
except it's not out yet because because
bloody YouTube has uploaded it but not
processed it this normally takes like a
couple of minutes after you upload this
has been about a half an hour so I'm
reloading it just in case but today's
its national pie day and every minute
that goes by is like another minute of
lost kind of attention not the best is
it still to be honest I'm just thrilled
that it's actually like done it will go
out at some point even if it's that
reupload but like let's not do that
again for a while for these okay a
slight change in title and
boom now I've just got to try and avoid
checking my analytics obsessively I did
this before I was a full-time youtuber
but I definitely do it more now oh I
know I can do hang on
time to update the video that this is
tracking that's a letdown so it's a
little bit later it's about 9:00 in the
evening and I have actually relaxed a
little bit I've done the video it's out
to sting quite well and people have been
leaving lovely comments so that's nice
this evening I've actually been working
on a video that's gonna be out in a few
weeks which is a really really exciting
collab it's possibly the most I've ever
been excited about a video I won't ruin
what it is gonna be about but this
evening I interviewed a friend of mine
that I met at Leeds who is doing a PhD
up there I interviewed him about his
research that's all I will say oh it's
good so cool so up until now this whole
vlog has been based in my car friends
called me so far in this vlog you've
only seen the inside of this room
because um I've been working on that pie
video pretty much for the entire week so
far tomorrow the studio isn't going to
feature at all well maybe a tiny bit
basically tomorrow we're gonna go
outside apparently there's a world out
there
[Music]
look there is a world out here there's
green and there's grain brown and oh
there's a bit blue sky I'll be honest
with you my own town attention it's not
the prettiest place in the world it may
not be the nicest place in the world
it's nice to be outside and not be
working on videos today actually I'm all
over the place there's gonna be quite an
interesting day so first of all I'm
recording an episode of my podcast the
wiki cast which is if you don't know I
have a podcast where my ex housemate and
I down click on random Wikipedia
articles and talk about what we find
I'll leave a link down there if you
would have a sitcom made about your life
what would it be like if you like I'm
imagining like the soft focus like you
only you're in focus as you walk into
like the Apple Store and it's like me
Daniel the newest employer the Apple
Store in Exeter he's got a dark secret
I'm actually just a bunch of mice in a
human suit and it zooms in sure it's
just a bunch of mice
they go okay cool that's running hi
there so I'm currently having my back
had a look at I'm a friend Fliss say hi
fellas
would you describe yourself as a
physiotherapist sports therapist so I am
in a lot of pain and I a knack of my
knees basically I did my knee how did
you describe my legs so when you first
it was it chronically tight yeah I was
not my legs were not happy bunnies so
we've done a little bit of physio to try
and even out my kinks and also have a
look at my back and you know just try
and hopefully get me running again you
said I could run the next week didn't
you yeah this is why you've got this
lovely view of my face because the
recipe is not fit for YouTube right now
when the rest of me is not fit full stop
but it's not fit for YouTube
[Music]
and that's the end of the presentation
[Applause]
that was the first time so what you
missed was that I just gave a talk at
Bristol Uni at the physics society chaos
and I'm joined by we've got the massage
man here that is I'm not just being mean
that is his online name because you want
to know a massive wiki cast reader and
you you said it's a fanfiction which we
did we read today
this boy is but I'm also joined we've
got some other people here it's oh I've
loved forgotten Oh Tommy and I still
don't know which way to point the camera
weight of the human varying stages of
fans of the vlog but apparently okay
I was Brady's warm-up act but how would
you describe the talk was it good simply
yeah I probably say that was mystic but
yeah I paid them to say that so that's
fine I will my to do calculate shirt
which I was told that other people were
gonna wear there sorry I didn't go to
Primark so I didn't get chance to make
where you will have to buy one when the
merchandise comes out very soon oh yeah
[Music]
all nighters really takes out of you
like I'm still feeling the effects today
this is this is two sleeps later I just
did I feel like I've got caught up not
gonna lie one the best things about my
dream we're in time it's that I can do
this
being youtuber to sub-sites I'm gonna
work
right so now that I'm honest with you I
really want nothing more than to take a
day off and just spend all day watching
warhammer videos but I have a podcast to
edit that's going to go out tomorrow and
there's also a nearly finished four
mercifully nearly finished video that's
gonna go at this weekend as well so I
need to get on that so I just finished
editing the wiki cast I was tempted to
do a little bit in the vlog but you've
already seen a million time lapses in
the editing or maybe haven't maybe that
would happen your first one in which
case hi but it'd be me trading or ground
and I thought maybe instead it would
more interesting to talk about how I
learned to edit I've never been taught
how to do video editing I actually did a
tiny bit of it when I was a kid without
even realizing when I made I took
computer classes when I was a kid my
parents sent me to whiz kids in bath and
so I spent like a Saturday morning every
week doing a few computer things it was
based on like worth next sell but there
was one game where you where you would
fly planes and complete missions but in
it was like a cinema mode and that was
the first time I edited anything was
just like uh you know it's just
naturally these are the shots that you
need in order to do this and I remember
I did this and the end of the session
like came and my parents came to pick me
up
they were like you should you should see
this we didn't tell them how to do it so
I use Adobe Premiere to edit my vlogs
and all my videos I do very little in
After Effects CU funnily enough that's
After Effects just on top of well it's
the render and rendering something from
After Effects which is the wiki cast
plug plug plug but use premiere for the
actual editing and that's for both audio
and video which is why I thought I'd
bring this up now apparently I'm quite
unusual for editing my podcast in
premiere most people would use audition
which is audio editing but I don't know
I just find it much easier in in
Premiere and I taught myself how to how
to use premiere in a very torturous
process because I could used to another
bit of editing software which was Sony
Vegas Sony Vegas is definitely
underpowered compared to premiere but it
was easier to pick up and it was also
cheaper I think it's a one-off cost and
then you don't have to pay like a
monthly thing like you do with the
premiere which is definitely worth it I
think my stage and being a creator
absolutely worth the money but when I
was starting I didn't want to invest
very much so that's that's advice I give
to people who are asked to like you know
editing advice is don't feel you have to
buy premium it is really good software
and it means you can edit for probably
anybody because most people use either
final cut or premiere but I started in
Vegas and I don't regret that I thought
it told me the basics quite quickly and
it got to the point where I felt like I
was brushing up against the ceiling of
what you could even accomplish in Vegas
whereas with premiere I'm not quite at
that point yet I kinda know there's some
stuff now Antone's after-effects but
yeah Vegas was cool and technically
before that I used iMovie I the first
video on my channel wasn't even edited
on a computer I owned I borrowed a
computer from Oxford University's
computing department i sat in the
computing services for like a whole
pretty much a whole day when we can't
and I just edited that video not not
using something that I owned because I
don't have a Mac that I movies pretty
good actually if you want to do just
basic stuff but yeah I can't use
premiere I think it's really cool I made
that whole video actually about like how
to edit vlogs so I will I'll leave that
in the description I stand by my advice
I give that I'd only be written it now
have I got anything else to share to be
honest the only other thing I'd add to
that video is that I taught myself all
of this by trial and error and by
following on my tutorials for like I
want to make something this is how far I
can get on my own oh and now I have to
look up how to do this one thing and
then every time I got to that one thing
whatever that thing was you know the
only change every time you expand your
knowledge a little bit and eventually
I've got to this point now where I can
pretty much edit anything see you if you
want my breakthrough editing advice try
stuff and if you don't know how to do it
giggle it pretty much the same as
learning to code and a programming
language to be honest I'm really quite
uncomfortable toys
[Music]
so something unexpected happened while I
say unexpected
behind me is a girlfriend hiding behind
her laptop so she surprised me by
turning out last night and there was me
trying to concentrate on work and she
was just typing on her laptop going yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum but
apparently this is what you now do and
what is yum yum yum yum yummy yum yum
this shot is so wonky yes it's
differently see you're teaching French
and you're teaching them to sound like
animals yeah that's that's blurred or I
could what I could do is cut out the
blaring and only have your tongue
unblurred but that's already done now
it's too late
yeah but all the same oh you're just
making my life more difficult now for
those of you new to the channel this is
pixel girl who is a teacher and so I had
to be very she has a secret identity
which is a you know real identity but
this is a typical girl
superhero please tell me over so now
pixel girls here unexpectedly we're
making these wonderful car blumpkin and
together we're going into town because
we can like it's actually snowing you
might have seen earlier there it's
actually snowing here because there's
another mini beast from the east of
Arctic weather which I'd like to take
credit for that's kind of research but
anyway we didn't want to walk is
everything to do my research I just what
are you leaving we're going into town to
work we're gonna see the delights of
kingship at 10 miles an hour
sorry people behind us we're obeying the
law
[Music]
behold the architectural delights of my
hometown which in this weather looks
like a Soviet gulag it's not the most
prepossessing place in the world it's
got to be said there are some nice bits
to it if you find them let me know even
the new stuff looks literally like a
prison I'm really close and right now
we're coming up to the epicenter this is
the room where it happens engaging this
is no exaggeration the bustling center
of town this is it guys it really says
something that people go excited when
the pound over so the health pics will
concentrate on work because she is a
very very busy person we've come to one
of the most empty coffee shops in the
west country which is very nice it's got
to be certain so we're going to be
powering through some work because we
don't take weekends I don't know do
people our age take weekends I think
some people who must do but
we don't we really should schedule some
time off
[Music]
for one night snow this is a lot hey we
found them a useful job a useful job
what can I say except you're welcome
hello chaps good morning garnished
lightly do something funny I look like I
do so I've just had to say goodbye to
pixel girl because she's got a lot of
work to do so she's going back off to
Cambridge but I kind of want to go
sledging it's minus 2 at the moment and
with the windchill it feels like minus 8
so time to wrap up warm alright so I'm
in sledging in quite a few years and the
last time it snowed here a few weeks ago
it was so horrible that nobody really
wanted to go sledding man because it was
literally like blizzard conditions now
though it's not snowing
not very much snow so hopefully
basically there's a big hill near where
I live I'm gonna meet up with somebody
I'm trying to try these some downhill
action yes
[Laughter]
better economics no better access
education yeah
valid my cocoa butter goodness
[Music]
[Music]
so you know how cancer is really bad
yeah well my phd's in cancer research we
know we're anti-cancer sure yeah
most further that was a bit ambiguous
like with Fireman Sam I know whose fault
profile my aunty fire so I look at how
we can use small proteins to target
cancer and I use computational biology
and wet lab biochemistry to do that it's
it's free tank which is how yeah
[Music]
I hit the rock Oh my prostate isn't in
the prostate if you know what I mean
right now so that was really fun
changed into something bit drier whilst
I was out I got an email confirming from
my sponsor which is brilliant dot org
that I could release the most recent
video it's actually at sequence um so
the NASA video which I'll leave a link
to down there I just went live which is
a little different from stuff I've done
before but it's it's done really well
like release wise the numbers in the
first I mean our in our nearly two hours
is gonna be about six thousand views
which for me is quite a quite a good
release really I can take this one off I
had intended for that video to come out
nearly a week ago actually and I had an
edited it apart from the footage from
the BBC and was on a DVD everyone who
went on that trip was given a DVD of the
footage and I just don't know where mine
was i I thought it was here at home
because it's not the kind of thing you
want to lose just nowhere to be found so
I had to ask loads of people who are on
the trip fortunately seem tell that
loads of people who actually lost their
discs which I thought was sad but turns
out one person had digitized it and they
had the files that so thank you so so
much it was Jerry my friend Joe who
sorted that out for me thank you Joe so
much your absolute babe and you know as
soon as I got that file it literally
took all of you know 20 minutes to just
put it in and tweak all the right little
bit so I'm yeah released better late
than never and actually was doing pretty
well so Sunday evening I'm now going to
spend a couple of hours doing some
editing including editing this vlog that
you're watching right now
I have to admit I've really enjoyed
vlogging this week
I think obviously doing the PhD there
was a point to making video blogs this
was the case of this is what my life's
like doing a PhD you know if you have
any questions ask me that this is this
is trying to make it more accessible to
kids like me who never knew anyone with
a PhD you know and trying to show that
anybody can do it you know had to be
superhuman to do a PhD thank God but
this time around being youtuber it's
like what was the point of the video
and up until certainly recently my life
wasn't interesting enough I think you
could argue it's not interesting enough
now my life wasn't interesting enough to
make a vlog other than this is me sat at
a computer editing maybe like one hour
two hours a week this is me filming or
this is me recalling you know now things
are shaping up that actually it's gonna
be kind of fairy there's gonna be a few
different things that I'm doing so maybe
I will give this a shot this hopefully
will be the first of a new series of
weekly vlogs like I really like the
weekly vlog format
Tom Scott Tom Ridge well his last week
series which is excellent and possibly
you know kind of partly inspired this
returned to me thinking about vlogging
so you know let's give this a go I'm
saying there's so much but let's give
this a go I will continue vlogging next
week and if you response to this video
is good and I enjoy doing it next week
then maybe let's see how how long this
can run for whilst you're down in the
comments also let me know what you
thought about the video and what what
you'd like to see in a vlog about
basically me being a science youtuber
you know what stuff you'd find
interesting if you enjoyed the video
give it a like give it a share what else
can you do put it in a playlist I get
statistics on that bait yeah you know
the YouTube is spilled by now right like
smash that like button everyone genuine
you know thanks for watching I hope that
you enjoyed this and um let me know what
you thought take care see you next time
[Music]